[Musik]
[Applaus]
die russische Militärmaschinerie kommt
wieder richtig in Gang die lang
erwartete Winteroffensive der Russen in
der Ostukraine hat begonnen dies liegen
so Intensität als auch der Einsatz von
Soldaten aus relativ neuen
kampfformationen nahe Putin hat seine
Armee den Befehl gegeben den Don Bass
bis spätestens März komplett zu erobern
egal zu welchem Preis die Eskalation der
Kämpfe war z.B um die Bergbau Stadt
wurde da deutlich wo die russische Armee
ihre am besten ausgebildeten
truppenstationiert hat falsche [__] und
marineisten
Russland hat wahrscheinlich eine ganze
Elite Brigade in der Nähe eine Bergbau
Stadt verloren fast die gesamte Brigade
wurde bereits in der Nähe von wo der
darauf verdichtet der ehemalige
russische paramilitär kennenzul Kopf
bestätigte auch telegram dass die
russischen Streitkräfte in der Nähe von
buchleda in Panzerkolonnen über schmale
Straßen verrückten mussten und sie
schließlich auftauchen laut schießt die
ukrainische Artillerie außergewöhnlich
genau mehr als 30 Einheiten gepanzerter
Fahrzeuge sein verloren Dutzende von
Panzersoldaten wurden getötet noch mehr
Marine Soldaten Spezialeinheiten und
motorisierte schützen starben all diese
Verluste erwiesen sich als einseitig die
Ukraine schossen auf die Angreifer wie
in einer Schießbude der Hauptangriff
findet jedoch entlang der Grenze
zwischen den Regionen Johannes und um
die Städte des Vaters und Kriminal statt
die ukrainische stadtkräfte griffen hier
noch Ende September an und entfernen
musste frisch eingezogene Truppen
einsetzen um den ukrainischen Vormarsch
zu stoppen was mit hohen Verlusten
verbunden war jetzt hat die russische
Armee jedoch wieder die Initiative
ergriffen und setzt die ukrainische
Armee unter Druck mit der Einnahmen von
bachmut im Norden 99
ukrainischen Verteidiger des Donbass in
einer zangenoperation eingeschlossen
werden um Ihnen dann mit weiteren neuen
Verbänden den daraus zu machen denn die
neu aufgestellte russische Streit macht
ist noch gar nicht von in Schwung
gekommen Einheit in der zweiten
motorisierten Artillerie die Version den
Januar aus Weißrussland in die Region du
hast verlegt worden sind bisher noch
nicht anders
Verteidigungsanlagen halten vorerst
stand und der Vormarsch der russischen
Truppen wird auf wenige Kilometer
begrenzt sein und das unter in kaufname
gewaltiger Verluste zum Teil über 1.000
Mann pro Tag laut der Analyse des
britischen Verteidigungsministeriums
haben die russischen Streitkräfte in den
vergangenen zwei Wochen die größten
Verluste seit dem Beginn ihrer Invasion
Erlebnis der Trend zeigt also eindeutig
dass die Zeit des ausharrenz vorüber ist
aber endet damit jede Phase des Krieges
der wie die moderne Version der Legende
von David gegen Goliat aussah ich meine
vor fast einem Jahr noch standen
russische
danach aber schieb Putins Armee in den
Seilen zu hängen wie ein Boxer den die
Puste ausgeht doch auch solche Boxer
sind immer noch gefährlich was wäre also
wenn Moskau sich berappeln und versuchen
würde die Situation umzukehren könnten
die Außen das schaffen nun die
Entschlossenheit zumindest ist durchaus
noch vorhanden dass man einen Blick auf
diese Nachricht Russland schließt Teil
Mobilisierung von Bürgern für den
Ukraine Krieg ab ja ich weiß diese
Meldung stammt aus dem November 2022 zum
Zeitpunkt der Erstellung diese Videos
22 ist noch nicht genau bekannt wie
viele neue Soldaten Russland wirklich
mobilisiert hat aber das Ziel waren eben
300.000 und fakt ist nun mal derzeit
befinden sich 300.000 russische Soldaten
in den von Russland besitzen
ukrainischen Gebieten ein weiterer Teil
befindet sich noch in der Ausbildung die
Qualität dieser neuen Truppen ist jedoch
eher gering die besten Einheiten und
hochwertigsten Waffen sind bereits
entweder zerstört oder stark beschädigt
worden und es ist unmöglich in ein paar
Monaten einen adäquaten Ersatz zu finden
schätzungen zufolge hat die russische
Armee im vergangenen Jahr sogar einen
großen Teil ihrer erfahrenen Ausbilder
verheißt die für die Ausbildung der neu
eingezogenen Soldaten eigentlich bitte
nötig gewesen wäre das gleiche gilt für
so gut wie alle Elite Verbände die
meisten davon Fallschirmjäger selbst
russische Militär Kommentatoren
behaupteten im Herbst dass die
russischen Luft Landetruppen als eigene
Gattung praktisch aufgehört hätten zu
existieren Fallschirmjäger mit ihrer
eher leichten Ausrüstung und ohne
Artillerie sind im Grabenkrieg aber
sowieso stark im Nachteil während also
sowieso wertlos dieser setzt du eher auf
die alte russische sowjetische keine
Strategie masse statt Klasse was den
Truppen an Ausbildung Erfahrung und
Ausrüstung fehlt soll durch pure
Mannstärke kompensiert werden und hier
scheint Putin wirklich zu klotzen statt
zu kleckern die Rede ist von der
doppelten malstärke im Vergleich zur
Truppe die vor einem Jahr in die Ukraine
einmarschiert ist aber nicht nur das
manche sagen die Zahlen könnten sogar
noch höher liegen Russland bereitet die
Mobilisierung von 500.000 zusätzlichen
vor behauptet die Ukraine alles deutet
darauf hin dass ich hier also etwas
Gewaltiges zusammenbaut wenn der
ukrainische Geheimdienst richtig liegt
könnte Russland bereits mehr als 280
Soldaten auf dem Schlachtfeld haben und
über die kommenden Monate vielleicht
noch 500 000 aufbringen mit anderen
Worten wenn es so kommt sprechen wir von
700 bis 800 000 Soldaten die sich auf
russischer Seite im Kampf befinden oder
dazu bereit sind und diese Zahlen sind
bei aller Stimmen und Inkompetenz
innerhalb der russischen Armee war nicht
kein Pappenstiel mehr
[Musik]
so oder so es steht ein episches
Massaker im Maßstab der beiden
Weltkriege bevor auch der besten scheint
mit einem ähnlichen Szenario zu rechnen
und er reagiert mit verstärkten
Waffenlieferungen die USA Großbritannien
und andere Verbündete kündigten seit
Jahresanfang fast täglich umfangreiche
Lieferungen schweren Gerät an alles und
der Ukraine zu helfen es geht um Waffen
die man vor einigen Monaten noch von der
Lieferung ausgeschlossen hatte
Kampfpanzer moderner Raketen und
mittlerweile debattiert man auch über
Kampfjets selbst Deutschland das bislang
als Bremse auf viel Stufen nachdem die
Bundesregierung in Verteidigungsminister
ausgewechselt haben Deutschland trinkt
EU Verbündete zur Lieferung von
leopardzeitpanzern an die Ukraine
Dänemark im Großteil seine Artillerie an
die Ukraine geliefert Dänemark spendet
19 französische Haubitzen vom Sarah an
die Ukraine entscheiden wird aber vor
allem die angekündigte Lieferung von
glsi langstreckenmunition für
artillerie-system sein die erste
ukrainischen Armee und ermöglichen
werden russische Logistikzentren in 150
km Reichweite das heißt im gesamten
okkupierten Gebiet zu zerstören und
damit ihre Versorgungslinien noch weiter
zu überdehnen
neue Waffe für die Ukraine wird die
Russen zum Rückzug zwingen die glsdbs
werden alle russischen Nachschublinien
im Osten des Landes sowie einen Teil
davon Russland besetzten Krim in
Reichweite der ukrainischen Artillerie
bringen dies wird Russland dazu zwingen
seine Nachschub noch weiter von der
Front zu entfernen was seine Soldaten
verwundbarer macht und die Pläne für
eine neue Offensive erheblich erschwert
so wie Heimat den Verlauf der Ereignisse
erheblich beeinflusst hat könnten diese
Raketen den Verlauf der Ereignisse noch
stärker beeinflussen die großen
russischen Depots befinden sich immer
noch außerhalb der Reichweite von
heimats die Russen sind in Front Nähe
auf kleine verstreute Depots und den
ständigen Nachschub per LKW angewiesen
die Versorgung eines Durchbruchs unter
diesen Bedingungen würde selbst die
modernste und effizienteste Armee der
Welt auf die Probe stellen und davon ist
die russische Armee Ebenen entfernt wir
erinnern uns die Russen verladen ihre
Munition noch immer Stück für Stück per
Hand die Logistik der Ukraine wird
hingegen trotz typischen dauerbombe bei
der Mars immer weiter ausgebaut und ja
die Ukraine verfügen sogar über die
beiden großen Hightech Geheimwaffen des
Westens Paletten und Gabelstapler tja da
können die Arme russischen Rekruten
wirklich nur staunen und sich fragen wie
sie eigentlich im Falle eines
Durchbruchs versorgt werden aber nicht
nur die Männer sondern vor allem Panzer
und alle anderen Fahrzeuge verschlingen
Unmengen an Treibstoff und Munition wenn
die vorrückenden Truppen nicht
regelmäßig mit Nachschub versorgt werden
können bleiben sie unweigerlich stecken
werden erst zu einer Belastung eine
Truppe und fallen schließlich den Feind
in die Hände ein Bild das wir aus diesem
Krieg aber nur also gut kennen Logistik
ist jedoch nicht das einzige Problem
500.000 zusätzliche rekrutierte Russen
sind eine Menge Soldaten und viele von
euch werden sich fragen wie können die
Russen die Rekruten zu kurzer Zeit
ausbilden und ausrüsten denn bisher
hatten sie ja ständig Probleme die
eigenen Männer ordentlich zu bewaffnen
oder sogar zu ernähren und das war auch
schon am Anfang der Invasion so als die
Arsenale der Russen noch gefüllt waren
wie soll das also in Zukunft laufen wenn
100.000 Soldaten hinzukommen und ja ihr
habt Recht die nur so vieler Truppen ist
keine leichte Aufgabe schon Putins Teil
Mobilisierung im vorigen Herbst war kein
leichtes Unterfangen für die
rekrutierungszentren aber wir sprechen
dennoch von 100.000 neuer Soldaten die
in Zukunft kommen könnten wie gut oder
schlecht die bewaffnet oder ausgebildet
sind ist deine Sache ihre Zahl aber eine
andere es handelt sich um eine Quantität
die ihre eigene Qualität hat das sollte
man nicht unterschätzen und ein Video zu
diesem Szenario ist uns das auf jeden
Fall wert die Frage die uns heute
stellen lautet also konnten die Russen
bei der letzten Mobilisierung wirklich
so viel Soldaten rekrutieren um den
Kriegsverlauf wieder zu ihrem Geburtstag
wie haben Sie das geschafft inwieweit
sollte tief besorgt sein wie wird der
weitere Kriegsverlauf Aussehen heute
werden all diese kritischen Fragen
natürlich ausführlich beantworten zuvor
würde ich jedoch noch gerne etwas in
eigener Sache loswerden und kurz auf ein
paar Reaktionen aus der Community
eingehen die die Finanzierung unseres
Kanals betreffen immer wieder wird
Kritik lauten würden zu viel Werbung
schalten zu viele Sponsoren einbauen und
dann auch noch Spenden verlangen die ist
aber nun mal das ein Kanal wie dieser
auf alle diese
Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten angewiesen
ist um den weiteren Betrieb
sicherzustellen denn selbst wenn wir all
dies voll ausschöpfen verfügen wir nur
über einen winzigen Bruchteil des
Budgets das zum Beispiel öffentlich
rechtlichen Fernsehproduktion zur
Verfügung steht die Werbeeinnahmen über
Google sind alles andere als konstant
zum Beispiel sind sie im Januar
gegenüber Dezember um mehr als 50 kostet
eingebrochen ja es handelt sich um einen
saisonalen Effekt aber das Geld fehlt
dann trotzdem in der Kasse eurer Spenden
wärmen unsere Herzen und wir sind euch
für jede davon unendlich dankbar aber
auch sie fließen er unregelmäßig und
würden doch nicht einmal dazu ausreichen
damit ein Mitarbeiter seinen
Lebensunterhalt bestreiten könnte und
die Wahrheit ist nun mal leider bekommen
wir wieder etwas umsonst noch verfügen
über einen großen Geldgeber im
Hintergrund die einen etwas
störungstheoretiker gerne meinen auf der
anderen Seite müssen aber eben Videos
der recherchiert geschrieben und
reagiert werden Material beschafft und
lizenziert werden in die Kamera sprechen
ist auch nicht gerade etwas was man nach
einem kleinen Arbeitstag noch gerne tut
und schließlich muss noch alles gesch
geprüft korrigiert gefilmt und
veröffentlicht werden und dann Strich
kann man sagen dass es tatsächlich die
Sponsoren sind die uns über Wasser
halten daher würde ich euch ganz lieb
darum bitten mit uns gnädig zu sein wenn
ihr Werbung für Sie in unsere Videos
integrieren wir versuchen dabei wirklich
sehr rücksichtsvoll zu handeln wir
machen keine Werbung für Glücksspiel
kryptowährungen oder sonstige Arten von
Investitionen mit denen ihr Geld
verlieren könnte ich markiere die
Werbeblöcke immer als eigene Kapitel
damit ihr sie überspringen können falls
euch die Werbung nicht interessiert das
gilt auch für diesen infoblog wir
versuchen auch immer langfristige
Werbepartner zu finden die der Community
einen echten Mehrwert bringen übrigens
falls ihr über Kontakte zu solchen
verfügt schreibt uns eine e-Mail
vielleicht könnten wir auf diese Weise
hier gute Strukturen finden und schreibt
uns ruhig in die Kommentare was ihr über
dieses Thema allgemein denkt aber gut
ich denke ich habe jetzt lange genug mit
unseren internen Geldsorgen zugetextet
wie gesagt zur Zeit sind dann auch auf
alle drei Quellen angewiesen Werbung
Sponsoren und eure Spenden habt also
bitte Verständnis dafür und den Spenden
Link findet ihr wie immer in der
Beschreibung in diesem Video ich bedanke
mich für eure Zeit und nun zurück zu
unserem Thema wie wird ein weitere
Kriegsverlauf unserer Einschätzung nach
aussehen also aufgepasst
das einzige was zählt die Quote
am 20 September 2022 hatte die Duma das
russische Parlament das
mobilisierungsgesetz verabschiedet
Russland wollte 300.000 neue Rekruten
ein Ziel so weiter planen aber konnte ab
da wirklich jeder Russe einfach so
eingezogen werden wie hat man die
Mobilisierung durchgezogen Null laut
Gesetz kam nicht jeder infrage die erste
Voraussetzung war dass die Rekruten
bereits über militärische Erfahrung
verfügen sollten zum Beispiel durch den
Einsatz gehen kann wer dann bei der
medizinischen Untersuchung nicht
ausgemustert wurde musste an die Front
da gab es keine Diskussionen das waren
Befehl wenn man das nicht wollte und
einfach vorher die Stadt verlassen hätte
dann drohte eine Gefängnisstrafe von
drei bis zehn Jahren natürlich kann man
auch kalkulieren der von Putin
versprochen sollte war gar nicht so
schlecht er behauptete dass jede
rekrutierte Person 195
000 Rubel erhalten würde umgerechnet
etwa 3000 $ pro Monat und das ist in
Russland schon ein stattliches Gehalt
wenn es überhaupt bei den Soldaten
ankommt laut einem Bericht sind 100
eingezogene russische Soldaten in den
Streit getreten und weigerten sich in
der Ukraine zu kämpfen weil sie nicht
bezahlt wurden mal abgesehen von den
Berichten über ausstehenden Zoll die
Mobilisierung hatte für die Regierung
einen politischen Preis ich meine wer
lässt sich schon gerne in einem Krieg
schicken
und sicher könnt ihr euch erinnern die
erstmobilisierung ankündigte gab es
Proteste in den Großstädten des Landes
tatsächlich hat Putin seither die Anzahl
seiner öffentlichen Auftritte erheblich
reduziert zum Beispiel hier der
üblicherweise am Ende jedes Jahres eine
Pressekonferenz mit Fragen aus der
Öffentlichkeit ab im Jahr 2022 war aber
Schluss mit dieser Tradition die
Konferenz wurde abgesagt genaue
Stimmungsbilder haben wir aus dem heute
abgeschotteten Russland nicht aber man
kann sich ja davon ausgehen dass ich ein
Staat nicht beliebt macht wenn er seine
Männer in den Krieg zwingt die
Mobilisierung hat aber natürlich auch
einen praktischen Aspekt wie konnte man
die Zahl von 300 000 Menschen
rekrutieren nun jede russische Region
verfügt über rekrutierungszentren für
die Quoten festgelegt werden das sind
dieselben rekrutierungszentren jedes
Jahr von etwa 260.000 jungen Menschen
durchlaufen werden um ihren Wehrdienst
abzuleisten doch die frischen mobics
haben sich nicht gerade freiwillig
gemeldet im Gegenteil die Menschen
verloren als die Mobilisierung kam sie
halten sogar schon dann ab als Gerüchte
über künftige ein Prüfungen aufkamen
sicher habt ihr vom Exodus viele junge
Russen gehört und die Bilder von den
Staus gesehen in Richtung Finnland oder
Georgien wir sprechen hier von immerhin
rund 700.000 Menschen aber was glaubt
ihr was mit denen passiert ist die es
nicht geschafft haben zu fliehen nun in
vielen Fällen machten sie so etwas seit
dem russischen einmal in der Ukraine gab
es mehr als ein Dutzend gemeldete
Versuche militärische Rekrutierungsbüros
in russischen Region in Brand zu setzen
in den Rekrutierungsbüros kam es zu
Beschwerden Protesten Brandanschlägen
und sogar Schießereien kurz gesagt diese
massive Mobilisierung im Herbst ist
nicht gerade reibungslos verlaufen aber
dennoch am 28 Oktober 2022 verkündete
Verteidigungsminister schulko den
erfolgreichen Abschluss der mobilisieren
aber stimmt das und konnten sie wirklich
300.000 Soldaten mobilisieren oder ist
das nur ein weiterer der vielen blödste
Russen gehen wir mal ins Detail jedes
Jahr für die russische Armee 2
rekrutierungskampagnen durch eine früher
und einen Herbst diese beiden Kampagnen
dauern etwa drei Monate jeweils und
130.000 richtige werden dabei
mobilisiert
den Herbst ging es aber darum mehr als
doppelt so viele Menschen in weniger
Asse hätte da Zeit zu rekrutieren dies
wurde natürlich erschwert durch Prozess
und Angriffe auf die
rekrutierungszentren und die Flucht
vieler junge Rosen trotzdem schätzen
viele Experten dass die Zahl 300.000
durchaus erfüllt wurde die Frage lautet
aber was für Leute hat man da eigentlich
rekrutiert
[Musik]
nun es wurden kriminelle eingezogen die
im Gefängnis saßen es gab auch in
Sendungen von Soldaten die die
Altersgrenze überschritten hatten aber
das sind alles Dinge die sogar der
kremme zugegeben hat es gibt jedoch den
Verdacht dass das mit den eingezogenen
knastbrüdern und den alten nur neben
kriegsätze sind ein Großteil der
Rekruten könnte von woanders herkommen
theoretisch ist eine Mobilisierung dazu
gedacht dass er wissen mit Kampf
Erfahrung oder zumindest Berufssoldaten
und keine einfachen Wehrpflichtigen aber
bedingt bitte das in Russland fast alle
Männer zwischen 18 und 27 Jahren einen
12 Monaten der dienstleisten müssen das
ist Pflicht das heißt zweimal im Jahr
gibt es rund 130.000 Wert wichtige die
kurz vor dem Ende ihrer 12 monatigen
Dienst verstehen und ist sie Leben
zurückkehren und glaubt ihr dass die
jetzt in den Krieg ziehen wollen und
kommen vor allem wenn man bedenkt was
russische Wehrpflichtige unter ihren
Vorgesetzten zu erleiden haben siehe das
Stichwort unser Video zum russischen
Militär man ist eher vor die Militärzeit
hinter sich zu haben
aber jetzt tot der Krieg die
Kriegsmaschinerie rechts nach frischen
Soldaten da wächst der Druck auf die
rekrutierungszentren die ihre Quoten im
Rahmen der Mobilisierung erfüllen müssen
und genau das wurde wohl auch vielen
entlassungskandidaten im Jahr 2022 zum
Verhängnis falls ihr langjährige
Zuschauer von das Wort Politik sagt
wisst ihr wie es in allen
Verwaltungsstrukturen des russischen
Staates so zugeht was alle Menschen in
diesem Apparat vom kleinen Beamten bis
hin zu Putin verbindet ist eine
unausrottbar verinnerlichte Kultur des
Lügens Lügen Lügen und noch mehr Lügen
das ist die Zauberformel mit der man in
Russland überlebt oder gar vorankommt
Hauptsache Vorstellungen und Vorgaben
von oben werden auf dem Papier erfüllt
und da wollten die Leiter der Zentren
ihre vorgesetzt natürlich bei Laune
halten die wiederum in hohen
generalstoffe alleine halten und so
weiter und so fort das Ergebnis man
setzt die entlassungskandidaten
irgendwie auf einen Beruf
soldatenvertrag und schickt sie in die
Ukraine und zwar mit welchen Mitteln
auch immer hauptsache es stimmt die
Quote die man nach oben meldet aber wie
viele entlassungskandid hat es denn nun
wirklich bei der letzten Mobilisierung
getroffen nun genau können wir das nicht
sagen aber es gab viele Berichte über
solche Praktiken und nach allem was man
über die russische Militärverwaltung
weiß liegt der Verdacht nahe das ist oft
so gelaufen ist auf jeden Fall reden wir
über 100.000 Menschen die frisch auf den
Schlachtfeldern in der Ukraine
angekommen sind oder noch ankommen
werden die Frage ist also inwieweit sie
das Gleichgewicht in Richtung Russland
verschieben könnten man genau das sehen
wir uns jetzt an
der Weg in einen Fleischwolf
seit der angeblich erfolgreichen
Mobilisierung sind 10.000 9 Soldaten in
die Ukraine verlegt worden die Frage ist
nun wofür hat Russland diese denn
mobilisiert offenbar bestimmt das erste
zitarren die geschwächten russischen
Linien zu verstärken dadurch wurde die
frontstabilisiert und ist gelang einige
kleine offensiven durchzuführen und
Gebiete zurück zu gewinnen nun hat Putin
wie gesagt den Befehl gegeben die
oblasten du kannst unseren jetzt bis
spätestens März 2023 einzunehmen und
zwar zu jedem Preis der ukrainische
Geheimdienst spricht gar von einem neuen
Angriff auf Kiew der von Weißrussland
aus Erfolg könnte um vom donpass
abzulenken und ukrainische Truppen im
Norden zu finden die Russen bereiten
neue Truppen vor ich habe keinen Zweifel
dass sie wieder auf Kiews losgehen
werden und es steht natürlich die Frage
im Raum ob Putins Ambitionen nicht
erneut auf einer krassen Fehler
Einschätzung der Fähigkeiten seine Armee
und die der Ukraine Bewohner so wie
bereits vor einem Jahr natürlich ist es
die eine Sache Leute von der Straße weg
oder aus Gefängnissen zu rekrutieren es
ist aber eine ganz andere sie für den
Krieg zu trainieren zu organisieren und
auszur wir alle wissen das Russland
damit große Probleme hat darüber haben
wir hier officialpolitik schon in vielen
früheren Videos gesprochen aber bleiben
wir mal beim Punkt Ausrüstung der
Soldaten hier versucht Russland wirklich
alles zusammen zu kratzen was geht
selbst bei den Uniformen sieht es düster
aus in einem eine Öffentlichkeit
gelangten Telefonat zwischen Putin und
seine verbünden lukaschen die bereits
versprochene Lieferung in Weißrussland
hergestellte Uniformen an Russland
einfach ab auch sonst hatte lukaschen
eine Bitte Putins und brüderliche Hilfe
Verständnis und weigerte sich sogar
viele seiner früheren Versprechen zu
erfüllen die Lage habe sich eben
geändert weiterhin musste Putin erfahren
dass lukaschen gar nicht nur aktiv mit
der chinesischen Führung kommuniziert
sondern sich vor kurzem auch mit einem
Vermittler getroffen hat dem hilft
Kontakte mit dem besten zu knüpfen
angeblich bereitet der Diktator für den
Mai eine amnestiefe hunderte von
politischen Gefangenen vor dies sollte
der erste Schritt zur Aufhebung von
Sanktion des Westens gegen Weißrussland
sein ja irgendwann wird es eben auch
einen kartoffelführer zu bunt aber zum
Thema Sanktionen konnte noch am Ende des
Videos nun zurück zum Militär
mittlerweile geht man in Russland dazu
über uraltes Militärgerät wieder
irgendwie flott zu machen zum Beispiel
bei Panzern t-62 Panzer aus den 1960er
Jahren werden da gerade generalüberholt
um sie in der Ukraine einzusetzen für
die frischen Soldaten ist das ein
ernstes Problem sie werden mit
aufgemogelten Schrott in die Schlacht
geschickt modernes Material gibt es
höchstens noch bei komplexeren Missionen
handelt es sich also um ein gefundenes
Fressen für die Ukraine nun nicht
unbedingt wie anfangs schon gesagt
bringt die schiere Masse hier eine
eigene Qualität mit sich das ganze hat
dann eben mehr von einer Zombie
Apokalypse denn von einem Krieg gegen
halbwegs normale Menschen der große
Unterschied ist natürlich das Zombies
normalerweise nicht schießen können und
Russland doch noch so einiges in den
langen Stehen hat was falsch ist aber
durchaus noch irgendwie schießen kann
solche Reserven sind bereits unterwegs
dass die russischen Truppen mittlerweile
mehr schweres Gerät bewegen die
Verlegung erfolgt aus der Nähe von
Johanns in die Gebiete nada aktuellen
Front zwischen Johannes und
wahrscheinlich werden sich die Russen
auf diese Region konzentrieren ebenso
wie auf das Gebiet und jetzt dort geht
es darum die Reste des Donners zu
erobern die Operation der letzten Wochen
hatten zum Ziel den ukrainischen Format
zu stoppen und verlorene Stellungen an
der Kriminal zurück zu erobern ihre
Taktik bestand jedoch fast
ausschließlich darin mit anhaltenden
Wellen vorne quasi kamikazeeinheiten
gegen die ukrainische Verteidigung zu
haben es handelte sich meist und Wagner
Truppen die fast jedem bestanden die am
meisten entbehrlich waren Häftlingen die
russische Militärmaschine kommt wieder
richtig in Gang die lang erwartete
Winteroffensive der Russen in der
Ostukraine hat begonnen dies legen
sowohl Intensität als auch der Einsatz
von Soldaten aus relativ neuen
Konfirmationen nahe die umbachmut
kämpfenden filterverbände der
berüchtigten wagnergruppe zieht Putin
jetzt allerdings komplett aus der
Ukraine ab wohl weil er befürchtet dass
ein Freund und Wagner bossin zur mächtig
werden könnte da setzt sich also gerade
im Creme so einiges in Bewegung dies
aber ist ein hochgradig spannendes Thema
für ein eigenes Video an dem wir gerade
arbeiten vergesst also bitte nicht
unseren Kanal zu abonnieren um es nicht
zu verpassen vorerst zumindest scheint
aber die Zeit der gehen himmelfahrenden
Verbrecher sollten dabei bachmut zu Ende
gegangen zu sein anders jedoch bei
Wochenende da wo wieder gut ausgebildete
falsche mega und Mitglieder der 155 und
40 Marinebrigade der Patienten zum
Einsatz kamen das Ergebnis allerdings
war ähnlich ernüchternd zwar wurde die
komplette Stadt in Erdboden gleich
gemacht ukrainische Offiziere sprachen
von einer Situation die schlimmer ist
als in bachmut aber die Eroberung der
Stadt gelangt den Russen auch unter
schwersten Verlusten nicht dabei
kämpften die Russen bei wurde da ganz
anders als in bachmord wo hunderte von
rekrutierten Kriminellen in den
gefrorenen Schützengräben starten die
Marines aus dem fernen Osten Russlands
greifen gemäß sowjetische Handbücher mit
Panzern und bewaffneten Mannschaft
Transportern an unterstützt von der
Luftwaffe und der Artillerie wenn sie
merken dass ein Angriff fehlschlägt
setzen Sie ihn nicht fort aber dass sie
nicht wie alle anderen sind nur so heißt
werden hat wohl auch viel damit zu tun
dass sie sich nicht mehr alles von ihre
Führung gefallen lassen denn die Marine
Infanteristen
november in die Schlagzeilen als sie bei
Paprika in der Nähe von wurde da schwere
Verluste erlitten und dann in einem
offenen Brief gegen die Dummheit ihrer
Kommandeure protestierten dies hat sich
für sie wohl ausgezahlt aber dass die
Kommandeure überhaupt auf ihre
schüsslinien hören hat natürlich auch
viel damit zu tun dass sie die wenigsten
russische Eliteeinheiten darstellen
Ausbildung Millionen verschlungen hat
die Durchführung einer erfolgreichen
Offensive mit kombinierten
Waffengattungen ist nun mal kein Ponyhof
und erfordert die Beherrschung Komplex
Operationen auf höchstem Niveau was uns
die Marine Infanteristen in wolle da
jedoch bewiesen haben ist die Tatsache
dass selbst einige angeblich besten
russischen Einheiten nicht in der Lage
sind derartige Operationen umzusetzen
russland hat wahrscheinlich eine ganze
Elite Brigade in der Nähe einer Bergbau
Stadt verloren die russischen
Streitkräfte verloren in der Nähe von
wurde da täglich 150 bis 300 Marine
Soldaten es wird geschätzt dass die
Brigade insgesamt etwa 5000 Soldaten
umfasste die nun getötet verwundet oder
gefangen genommen worden ukrainische
Soldaten veröffentlichten auch ein Video
das zeigt wie russische Truppen in
panikeraten und sich auf einem
Schlachtfeld bei Wohle der stauen die
155er musste bereits drei Mal neu
besetzt werden das erste Mal nach ihren
und Botschaft das zweite Mal als sie bei
Don jetzt besiegt wurde sie erholte sich
wieder und jetzt wurde fast die gesamte
Brigade bereits bei hochlegal vernichtet
[Musik]
das Ergebnis sieht für die Russen also
immer gleich aus egal ob es sich um
schnelle rekrutierte mobics
häftlingshorden oder Eliteeinheiten
handelt und egal ob diese bewusst in den
Tod geschickt werden oder einigermaßen
vorsichtig vorgehen ihnen allen gemein
ist die schnelle Vernichtung durch zwar
zahlenmäßig unterlegene jedoch Waffen
und aufklärungstechnischer wie taktisch
überlegene Ukraine außerdem hat sich
dort gezeigt dass selbst diese
schlüsseleinheiten im Rahmen der
herzmobil machen nicht richtig
aufgefüllt werden konnten als die
Ukraine vor kurzem viel Mitglieder der
155 Brigade in einem erfolgreichen
Hinterhalt gefallen Namen stellte sich
heraus dass es sich um 18 bis 19 jährige
Jungen aus gehandelte jemand kaum als
Elite Soldaten bezeichnen konnte dies
alles deutet bereits jetzt darauf hin
dass es den Russen nicht gelungen ist
die neue mobilisierten Kräfte
hinreichend auszubilden daher wird auch
nicht viel von ihnen erwartet
insbesondere bei einer militärisch
äußerst anspruchsvollen Offensive es ist
daher möglich dass die russischen
Generäle in den kommenden Wochen erneut
in eine Stra europäische Falle laufen
indem sie versuchen werden die
Forderungen des Krems zu erfüllen auch
wenn die Armee nicht über genügend
ausgebildete Kräfte für einen
erfolgreichen Angriff verfügt denn die
Grundregel vor allem im modernen Krieg
lautet Ausbildung und Erfahrung sind das
entscheidende Element für den Erfolg und
bisher konnten wir nicht sagen dass der
erste feinkontakt der neuen Rekruten
also gut verlaufen wäre die miese
Ausbildung Ausrüstung war und ist ein
großes Handicap in den meisten Fällen
ist die Mobilisierung zu einer echten
Hülle für die Russen geworden
letztendlich sind die meisten von ihnen
nichts weiter als warme Körper die Putin
auf das Schlachtfeld wirft bisher waren
sie für Putin nichts als das Material um
die frontenstabilisieren und die Ukraine
aufzuhalten solange er auf das Ende des
Winters wartete was Ihre Kunden erwartet
ist also ziemlich düster und viele von
ihnen wissen das zwei Wochen Training
bereiten dich nicht darauf vor ein
russischer Rekord gegenüber dem guardien
nehmen wir den Fall von Alexa gefunden
auf der zusammen mit 570 anderen Männern
aus der Regionen rekrutiert wurde in
einem Interview mit der Zeitungen
erzählte er von seinem katastrophalen
Erfahrungen an der Front unter anderem
erklärte er das von den 570 Rekruten
nach ein paar Wochen nur noch 130 am
Leben waren viele der Überlebenden haben
nach dem was passiert ist den Verstand
verloren niemand will dorthin
zurückkehren wir waren völlig
ungeschützt Aussagen eines russischen
Rekruten gegenüber dem Guardian okay
schlecht trainierte und mies ausgerüste
Düsseldorf
Ressourcen eines ganzen Landes nur eine
wirklich starke Wirtschaft kann die
hohen Produktionsraten an Waffen
aufrecht erhalten und genau darum geht
es im nächsten Kapitel also aufgepasst
woher sollen die Waffen kommen
rechnet mal nach 700.000 Russen haben
das Land verlassen weitere 300.000 gehen
in Folge der letzten Mobilisierung in
die Ukraine insgesamt sprechen wir also
von einer Million Arbeitnehmern die dem
Land nicht mehr zur Verfügung stehen das
sind mehr als 1,4% der arbeitenden
Bevölkerung Russlands und
schätzungsweise mehr als 2% wenn es zu
einem weiteren Einberufung kommt und das
sind wahrlich große Zahlen vor allem
wenn wir bedenken dass es sich bei den
geflohenen Rosen häufig um junge und
hochqualifizierte Menschen handelt zu
diesem Verlust gesetzlich noch ein
weiterer hinzu die russische
Gesellschaft Alter sehr stark es gibt
einfach zu wenig Arbeitswege Leute im
Land die eine ziehen in den Krieg die
anderen geht in Rente daher ist es nicht
nur eine Frage der Leidensfähigkeit der
Russen ob eine Kriegswirtschaft auf die
Beine gestellt werden kann die die
Kriegsmaschine die langfristig versorgen
könnte es geht schlicht und ergreifend
darum wer überhaupt all die Waffen
herstellen soll die die russische Armee
so dringend braucht ja stimmt es sind
jede von der Mobilisierung
ausgeschlossen die in Rüstungsbetrieben
arbeiten aber das reicht eben nicht aus
und das gehen sogar die russischen
Behörden zu der Personalmangel in den
russischen Rüstungsbetrieben beträgt
etwa 400.000 Arbeiter aber so neu sind
diese Probleme gar nicht sie sind sogar
typisch für den militärischindustriellen
Komplex der Russen ein Beispiel im Jahr
2017 war das russische
Rüstungsunternehmen NPO novator in der
Lage nur 60 Raketen in sechs Monaten zu
produzieren wie ihr euch vorstellen
könnt erfordert die Intensität des
Krieges viel viel mehr als das russland
hat so weil mehr als 120 Raketen an
einem einzigen Tag abgeschossen also
mehr als doppelt so viel wie die eben
erwähnte raketenfabrik in einem halben
Jahr herstellen kann und nicht nur das
es wird geschätzt dass Russland alleine
im November 2020 fast 20.000 Artillerie
geschossen abgefeuert hat pro Tag
[Musik]
hochgerechnet sind das eine halbe
Million Geschosse pro Monat außerdem
haben sie in einem Monat nicht weniger
als 1.200 kalibra Raketen abgeschossen
nach Angaben des Royal United Services
Institute gab es Phasen in denen
Russland in knapp einer Woche mehr
Munition verschossen als die britische
Armee insgesamt besitzt darüber hinaus
haben die russischen Streitkräfte
bereits fast alle ihre eskante
Kurzstreckenraketen eingesetzt
[Musik]
mit anderen Worten die russische Armee
ist mit zwei großen Problemen zur
gleichen Zeit konfrontiert sie
verbraucht ihre Waffen in einem sehr
schnellen Tempo und sie schafft es nicht
mehr Waffen in der erforderlichen Menge
zu produzieren große Waffen Zulieferer
aus dem Ausland fallen weg China liefert
nicht oder zumindest nicht so viel wie
man im Westen anfangs befürchtete oder
putinessig erhoffte und es gibt noch
einen weiteren Faktor der die Lage von
Russland schwierig macht die
internationalen Sanktionen
seht es mal so herkömmliche dumme
Munition für ein Gewehr oder der
Haubitze sind die eine Sache
Präzisionsraketen eine ganz andere für
normale Geschosse hat Russland die
Materialien und die
Produktionskapazitäten das einzige woran
ist da krank ist die ineffiziente
Industrie und das Produktionstempo aber
bei intelligenter präzisionsmunition ist
das eine ganz andere Geschichte eine
große Anzahl russische Raketen ist mit
Mikrochips ausgestattet die bislang vom
Besten geliefert wurden Russland wird
daher aufgrund der Sanktionen
Schwierigkeiten haben Präzisionsraketen
nachzubauen weil es an diesen
schützenmangelt laut einem Bericht
werden russische Waffen in der Ukraine
mit hunderten von westlichen Teilen
betrieben diese Komponenten werden nur
in einigen billigen Ländern hergestellt
wir sprechen hier vor allem über Taiwan
Südkorea die Vereinigten Staaten die
Niederlande Deutschland das Vereinigte
Königreich und Japan allesamt Verbündete
der Ukraine natürlich versucht Russland
irgendwie diese Sanktion zu umgehen aber
das erhöht die Kosten für die Russen
deutlich und es ändert wenig am
Missverhältnis zwischen Angebot und
Nachfrage durch den intensiven Krieg
kein also das ist dazu Notlösungen kommt
wie dieser hier wir haben Berichte von
Ukrainern das russische
Militärausrüstung diese finden voller
Halbleiter sind die sie aus
Geschirrspülen und Kühlschränken
genommen haben nun ja vielleicht erklärt
das ja die Berichte über russische
Soldaten die massenweise Kühlschränke
und Waschmaschinen geklaut haben aber
Spaß beiseite denn wenn man all das
berücksichtigt stellt sich natürlich die
Frage was tut potent um das zu ändern
[Musik]
nun im Januar versprache zum Beispiel
das endlich auch sein wunderbar
in der Ukraine zum Einsatz kommen würde
um die aus dem besten eintretenden
Panzer Leopard 2 und Challenger zu
kontern damit würde sich das Blatt auf
dem Schlachtfeld endgültig zu Gunsten
Russland Senden der einzig sei dann nur
noch eine Frage der Zeit und siehe da
nur Wochen später zwei Tage vor der
Aufnahme dieses Videos wurde ein stolzes
Exemplar des aramata ein freier
ukrainischer Bildband gesichtet
doch müssen die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte deswegen nun in angststörer
verfallen nein im Gegenteil der armata
könnte sich eher als wunderbar für im
Sinne eines Monty pythischen tödlichen
Business entpuppen
[Applaus]
dieses Rüstungsprojekt ist der Inbegriff
für alles was mit der russischen
Militärindustrie nicht stimmt grandiose
Pläne gestohlene Milliarden Abhängigkeit
von westliche Technologie und als
Ergebnis ein dysfunktionales
Waffensystem das für die Russen selbst
eine Lachnummer ist nun ja zumindest für
ihre Russen die über einen minimalen
Einblick in den russischen militärischen
industriellen Komplex verfügen der t-14
ist ein schlecht funktionierendes und
vor allem unfertiges Waffensystem mit
einem problematischen Motor der gar
nicht ständige Anwesenheit eines Teams
von werkstechnikern erfordert auf dem
Schlachtfeld der Grund dafür nun wieder
bereits in früheren Videos über die
russische Militärindustrie betont haben
ist Serienproduktion eine um zickgrößten
Ordnungen komplexere technische
historisch und finanzielle
Herausforderung als sie bloße Produktion
von Prototypen tatsächlich ist selbst
das Testen eines Prototyps und dessen
Feinabstimmung zum Endprodukt ein viel
komplexer Prozess als die Herstellung
eines Prototyps an sich und die bisher
verfügbaren armata wurden nicht nur
nicht in Serie produziert dann sind auch
noch nicht einmal ausreichend getestet
worden ein rüstungsprodukt in einem
derartigen reifengrad auf dem
Schlachtfeld einzusetzen gleich daher
gerade zu einer Kamikaze Mission nur
eben einer verdammt teuren Kamikaze
Mission aber bislang konnte dies den
kremmenhersteller natürlich herzlich
egal sein denn ausgerechnet aufgrund des
von ihm entfachten Kriege geschossen die
Rohstoffpreise 2022 in die Höhe was
Russland überdurchschnittlich hohe
Exporteinnahmen beschädigt dadurch
konnte es ein Teil der sanktions Folgen
kompensieren und besonders im
Verteidigungssektor noch einmal statt
investieren allerdings handelt es sich
beim rohstoffpunkt 2022 um eine eher
kurzfristige Finanzspritze denn
mittlerweile stand der das Jahr 2023 die
Rohstoffpreise sind nach dem teuren
Umbau der Lieferwege weitgehend wieder
auf vorkriegsnive gesunken und dem
russischen Staatshaushalt klafft nun ein
Haushaltsloch von 44 Milliarden Euro das
entspricht 2,3% des russischen BIP
tatsächlich sind die Einnahmen Russlands
aus dem Erdöl und Erdgasgeschäft dieses
Jahr im Vergleich zum Januar 2022 um
sage und schreibe 46%, also fast die
Hälfte eingebrochen gleichzeitig sind
die Staatsausgaben gegenüber dem Vorjahr
um 59% rund 40 Milliarden Euro in die
Höhe gestellt dies alles zwang das
russische Finanzministerium nun sogar
dazu Teil seiner Gold und Johannes
Reserven auf den Markt zu werfen um die
Lücken im Staatshaushalt notdürftig
stopfen zu können man sieht also die
wirtschaftssanktion des Westens wirken
langsam aber sie wirken 2023 dürfte
fiskalisch also ein wirklich heißes Jahr
werden für die Russen der die Sanktionen
können sich nun wesentlich besser
auswirken als 2022 putin wird immer
weniger Handlungsspielraum bleiben und
er wird alle möglichen Beziehungen
ausnutzen müssen um noch einigermaßen
brauchbare Waffen zusammen zu kratzen
ein Beispiel dafür waren z.B die
Lieferungen iranischer Drohnen die der
Diktator nutzte um die Ukraine zu
terrorisieren und auf die dro verfolgten
meist ballistische Kurzstreckenraketen
ebenfalls aus iranischer Produktion und
zwar vom 110 und soll vergangen deshalb
gibt es seitens westliche Länder bereits
neue Sanktionen gegen iranische
Geschäftsleute und Beamte die an die
Waffenhandel zwischen Iran und Russland
beteiligt sind US-Außenminister Anthony
blinken sagte dazu folgen die
Vereinigten Staaten werden weiterhin
alle ihnen zur Verfügung stehenden
Mittel einsetzen um solche Transfers zu
unterbinden und denjenigen die an
solchen Aktivitäten beteiligt sind
Konsequenzen auferlegen mittlerweile hat
sich Israel dass ich zunächst neutral
behalten wollte angekündigt seine
Position zum Krieg in der Ukraine zu
überdenken und hinter den Kulissen
scheint dieser Paradigmenwechsel bereits
stattgefunden zu haben als im Iran eine
drohnenfabrik die Rosen gelieferte in
die Luft geflogen ist über den auf den
plane Spieler Israel bereiten will
gerade ein eigenes Video vor vergesst
also bitte nicht das Abo unbedingt mit
Glöckchen um keines unserer Videos mehr
zu verpassen ach ja und dabei immer noch
gefragt werden wieso das Glöckchen so
wichtig ist es ist nicht nur für uns
richtig sondern vor allem für euch es
befreit euch nämlich aus der totalen
Abhängigkeit vom Youtube Algorithmus
lasst euch oh ja Sehverhalten nicht
komplett durch Algorithmen dieser
Großkonzerne vorschreiben sondern nutzt
das Glöckchen um selbstbestimmt youtube
gucken zu können aber zurück zu Russland
Waffenbeschaffung die USA haben ja
Russland auch beschuldigt Waffen aus
Nordkorea zu kaufen das wurde von
Russland natürlich als reine Spekulation
zurückgewiesen tatsache ist aber dass
die Russen mit oder ohne die
Nordkoreaner bereits damit begonnen
haben uralte Munition zu verwenden in
einigen Fällen könnte es sich um Rakete
und Geschosse handeln die vor 40 Jahren
hergestellt wurden während das Tor wird
Ära und was passiert wenn man altes
Material verwendet könnt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich denken der Anteil eine
hohe kreativ und windgängern steigt
immer weiter denn selbst Artillerie
Munition hat ein Haltbarkeitsdatum und
wenn man es nicht beachtet kann dies für
die Soldaten die Munition benutzen
sollen sehr unangenehm enden aber machen
wir uns nichts vor all das erscheint
zwar wie ein Vorteil für Tiere aber es
hat einen tödlichen Beigeschmack
es bedeutet das Granaten die noch nicht
explodiert sind dies später immer noch
tun können alte Blindgänger können noch
in Jahrzehnten unschuldigen Menschen das
Leben kosten aber nicht nur das Herr
Russland bisher nicht in der Lage war
den Krieg zu gewinnen greift es
leichtere Ziele an also Wohngebäude
Schulen Kindergärten Krankenhäuser und
Kraftwerke für die Energieversorgung
natürlich sind das Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit aber Russland weiß das
und tut es trotzdem will damit den
ukrainischen Widerstand brechen und sie
zu Verhandlungen unter seinen
Bedingungen denken russischer
Raketenangriff auf Wohnhaus in nikot
tötet 40 Menschen sieht es doch mal so
was nützt ist ein Wohnhaus zu verstören
militärisch hat ist keinerlei Bedeutung
warum sollten russische Angriff planen
nur der Grund ist einfach sie können
nichts anderes sie hoffen mit
barbarischen Angriffen die durchhalten
will der Ukraine zu brechen es ist die
gleiche Strategie die sie bei Angriffen
auf Kraftwerke Stromnetze und Wasser
Aufbereitungsanlagen angebracht haben
ein Beispiel der ihm erwähnte Angriff
auf mir braucht wurde mit KH 22 Raketen
durchgeführt dieser Raketen stammen noch
aus ist soweit era und waren
ursprünglich für ein völlig anderen
Einsatz vorgesehen und zwar gegen
westliche Marine Verbände vor allem
amerikanische Flugzeugträger die Raketen
treffen nur sehr ungenau jetzt Ziel denn
in ihrer ursprünglichen einsatzrolle
reicht es aus einem nuklearsprenkopf in
die Nähe des Ziels zu tragen da kam es
auch Präzision nicht so an aber leider
Ukraine derzeit nicht über die Waffen um
diese Raketen abzufangen deswegen
beschießt Ausland mit diesen Raketen
dicht besiedelte Wohngebiete und tötet
damit Frauen und Kinder
auch hier wieder das gleiche Kalkül die
Waffen müssen nicht genau treffen
sondern nur größtmöglichen willkürlichen
Schaden anrichten und möglichst viel
Zivilisten töten es handelt sich
allesamt um Taktiken eines Aggressors
der militärisch nicht die Überhand
gewinnen kann aber dennoch den
Widerstand brechen will einen Widerstand
der jedoch umso stärker wächst die
brutale der russische Diktator gegen die
ukrainische Bevölkerung hämmert laut
einer Umfrage im Januar sind nur 8 % der
Ukraine dazu bereit im Rahmen eines
potenziellen Friedensabkommens auf
Territorium zu verzichten das heißt auch
nach 10 Monaten zermürbenden und
brutalen Krieges ständigen wollen muss
und das dadurch entstanden Elends
bleiben die Ukraine standhaft und leben
das leider auch im Westen oft gesungen
und aktiv von der Notwendigkeit
territorial dazugeständnisse für
Bestätigung des Aggressors von Grund
heraus ab nein dieses Volk lässt sich
nicht so leicht brechen wieder mit
brutalste Gewalt noch mit viele
scheinheiligen friedensabellen
[Musik]
das alles wollen wieder Putin noch seine
westlichen apologen verstehen ebenso wie
die Tatsache dass er seine Militär nicht
einfach zu befehlen kann mehr zu tun als
es überhaupt zu bewältigen in der Lage
ist aber dies ist vielleicht das
wichtigste Charakteristikum dieses
Krieges er hat tief im Kopf eines in
einem Bunker hinter seinem Schreibtisch
vertrocknen Mannes begonnen und er wird
auch genau dort enden ist Russland also
dazu verdammt diesen Krieg zu verlieren
marschieren all diese 100.000 9 Soldaten
direkt in eine Art riesigen Fleischwolf
nun in gewisser Weise ja denn selbst die
Ukraine noch irgendwie zu einem
Friedensabkommen mit gebietsabtretung
Zwingen sollte Russland wird auf
Jahrzehnte hin stark geschwächtigt sein
und geostrategisch an Einfluss verlieren
wir müssen aber auch die andere Seite
der Medaille betrachten die Ukraine ist
bei der Bewaffnung ihrer Armee völlig
abhängig von westliche Hilfe das heißt
die militärischen Fähigkeiten der
Ukraine hängt nicht nur von ihr selbst
darf sondern von der internationalen
Solidarität und dem politischen Willen
im Westen und das könnte zu einem
Problem werden falls die öffentliche
Stimmung in einigen europäischen Ländern
oder in den USA kippen sollte außerdem
selbst wenn der Westen weiterhin
Munition liefert haben auch die Arsenale
Europas und der Vereinigten Staaten ihre
Grenzen Nachrichten wie diese zeigen es
auf Europa liefert einige Waffen an die
Ukraine aber die Munition geht aus
Westeuropa stößt definitiv schon an
seine Grenzen mit seinen schlechte
ausgerüsteten und ja es ist das Ergebnis
eines Jahrzehnte langen
sicherheitspolitischen Versagens wieder
einmal zeigt sich die totale
militärische Abhängigkeit von Land die
USA greifen ihrerseits auf die riesigen
Vorräte zurück wie sehen Israel und
Südkorea für kriegsfälle angelegt haben
und das alleine sollte den Bedarf an
konventionelle Munition noch eine Weile
aber nicht endlos denken daher wird die
munitionsproduktion in den USA und
vielen Verbündeten Ländern derzeit
massiv hochgefahren auf jeden Fall sind
die Alliierten noch nicht an einem
kritischen Punkt angelangt die letzten
Wochen sind ein guter Beweis dafür die
Lagerhäuser sind noch immer voll kannst
du schweigen vom immensen Potential der
gesamten westlichen Militärindustrie die
bisher noch immer zu einem Bruchteil
ihrer Möglichkeiten hochgefahren wurde
und letzten Endes haben die ersten
beiden Wochen der russischen
Winteroffensive bei bachmut und wohlhada
gezeigt dass die russischen Streitkräfte
noch immer nicht in der Lage sind
effektive offensiv-operation zu führen
offensiv-operation die in der Lage wären
die ukrainische Verteidigung so zu
berechnen dass signifikante Gelände
Gewinne erzielt werden könnten selbst
wenn einzelne russische vorschlüsse auf
der Landkarte erfolgreich Aussehen
handelt es sich nur um kleine
instrumental Gewinne die mit enormen
Verlusten an Gerät und man bezahlt
werden müssen bisher gibt es also keine
Anzeichen dafür dass die Russen es
geschafft hätten eine ganzheitlich
erfolgreiche kombinierte Kriegsführung
auf die Beine zu stellen die Ihnen eine
wirkliche Wende des Kriegsverlaufs
ermöglichen würde denn vor allem im
Punkte lernen und Anpassungsfähigkeit
hinten die Russen den Ukraine nicht nur
erheblichen hinterher sondern sie fallen
immer weiter zurück und putinska kühle
Russland könne mal wieder ein Krieg
gewinnen indem es dem Feind dumme aber
gewaltige Horden entgegenwirkt passiert
auf einem vollkommen verfilmten
Geschichtsverständnis ja ohne die Hilfe
Washingtons würde man heute in Moskau
oder wieder geographische Ort an dort
dieser Stelle dann heißen würde Deutsch
sprechen und vor allem 1917 ist diese
Strategie nicht aufgegangen und in dem
1980er Jahren in Afghanistan schon gar
nicht da schon damals die demografischen
Voraussetzungen für ihre
Durchführbarkeit sowohl an der Feindes
als auch in der Heimatfront nicht
gegeben waren und 40 Jahre später ist
die Demographie Russland noch wesentlich
schlechter eine einzige Katastrophe wie
will man unter diesen Voraussetzungen
die zweit unmenschlichte und zwei
dümmste Form der Kriegsführung
durchhalten aber falls ihr euch fragt
was denn überhaupt die unmenschlichste
und alle dümmste Form ist das ist der
Atomkrieg und dies wissen zum Glück
sowohl Putin als auch seine Clique
[Musik]
fassen wir also zusammen ein Jahr nach
den Beginn ihrer Invasion und nach fünf
Monaten mobil machen sind die russischen
Streitkräfte schwächer als vor den 24
Februar 2022 trotzdem werden ihre
Fähigkeiten von zahlreichen Experten
immer noch maßlos überschätzt dabei geht
es nicht nur darum dass sie Unmengen an
Material und ihrer besten Truppen
verloren haben nein es geht vor allem
darum dass ich die für ihre miserable
Performance Verantwortlichen Probleme
noch weiter vertieft haben schlechte
Aufklärung chaotische Kommunikation über
den Logistik sowie der eklatante Mangel
an Unteroffizieren und
präzisionsmunition es existiert auch
keinerlei Perspektive dass die Russen
diese Defizite in Zukunft beseitigen
könnten währenddessen hatte ich sowohl
die Ausrüstung als auch der
Ausbildungsberater ukrainischen
Streitkräfte massiv gebessert die
russische Armee hat der neue
eintretenden langstreckenmunitionen GLS
DB und somit der Zerstörung ihrer
Versorgungslinien auf ist 150 km hinter
der Front nichts entgegenzusetzen und
sie verfügt auch über keinerlei
Strategie die daran etwas ändern könnte
damit wird für sie nicht nur die
Durchführung einer groß angelegten
Offensive wieder zum
himmelfahrstkommando es wird für sie
auch extrem schwierig werden ihre dann
schwer zu versorgenden
defensivpositionen zu halten sobald die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive nach
eintreffenden neuen Panzerverbände aus
dem Westen möglich wird und auf die
Tatsache dass die neue große russische
Offensive zum rockerpierer werden und
keinen wirklichen Durchbruch bringen
könnte stellt sich mittlerweile sogar
schon die russischen chefantanisten ein
[Musik]
klappten und Co noch vor kurzem der
Blitz Krieg gegen die Ukraine sein
deswegen nicht gelungen bei der besten
der Ukraine um Russland in einen
langjährigen Konflikten anzuziehen
brauchten sie jetzt das Gegenteil
plötzlich sagen sie ein langer Krieg
wäre für Moskau eigentlich das
allerbeste eine List Putins und die
Ukraine auszubluten und den Westen zu
erleben ja tatsächlich könnten wir bald
erleben dass das Putin Regime genau in
diese Richtung steuert wenn die
Winteroffensive im Sande verläuft wie
gesagt sind die Rosen ein leidensfähiges
Volk die Versorgung mit Gütern des
Grundbedarfs ist relativ autark und man
wird weiterhin Öl ein Drittländer
verkaufen können um sich irgendwie über
Wasser zu halten ein kompletter
Zusammenbruch der russischen Wirtschaft
kann so verhindert werden und Putin kann
den Krieg und den Terror gegen die
Ukraine und andere Nachbarländer dann
quasi auch Sparflamme sehr lange
weiterführen allein schon deswegen um
sich um seine Clique an der Macht und
die Welt in Atem zu halten und zwar auch
nach einem Waffenstillstand oder gab
Friedensabkommen denn wie wir in der
Vergangenheit gesehen haben sind
Abkommen das Letzte woran er sich hält
und das einzige was ihn an der um und
dieses Dauer Terror Szenarios des
russischen Schreckens ohne Ende hindern
kann ist die kritische Vernichtung der
russischen Streitmacht durch eine vom
Besten gut ausgerüstete und ausgebildete
ukrainische Armee
top US-General ade Jets könnten
schnellen Sieg der Ukraine besiegeln der
ehemalige kommandierer der US-General in
Europa Ben Hodges hat gegenüber der
Deutschen Welle erklärt dass der besten
Kiew mit Kampfjet versorgen sollte was
zu einem Sieg Kiews innerhalb eines
Jahres führen könnte er sagte voraus
dass die Niederlage Russland bei der
derzeitigen Unterstützung durch den
Westen sonst drei bis fünf Jahre dauern
könnte und betonte das kifft die Krim
zurückerobernüsse um die internationale
regelbasierte Ordnung und die un-karte
zu bewahren aber was meint ihr
eigentlich wird die Hilfe des bestens
für die Ukraine ausreichen um den Krieg
zu gewinnen was haltet ihr von Russland
Strategie nach dem Motto masse statt
Klasse wenn ihr das unsere Analyse
stichhaltig war und unsere
Einschätzungen eintreten werden die
immer sind wir auf eure Diskussion zu
diesem Thema schon richtig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und mir vielleicht aber auch das
gelernt haben was ja gibt uns mit einem
Freund gesagt nicht das Abo mit
öffentlichen um keines unserer Videos zu
verpassen natürlich freuen uns auch
jederzeit auch wie gesagt über eine
Spende von euch Medien helfen dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen Link dazu findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video
[Musik]